From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. If you're living in a city, you may have noticed new buildings popping up. A high rise here, a skyscraper there. These concrete jungles make urban living possible. They allow millions to live together in close proximity and allow modern economies to flourish. But is there something important missing in this picture? For most of the last two million years, humans lived in a natural world, relying on nature for food and shelter.
这里是NPR的《Hidden Brain》，我是主持人尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。如果你住在城市里，可能已经注意到新建的建筑层出不穷。这里一栋高楼，那里一座摩天大楼。这些钢筋水泥丛林让城市生活成为可能。它们让数百万人能够近距离地生活在一起，并推动了现代经济的繁荣。但在这个画面中，是否缺少了什么重要的东西？在过去两百万年的大部分时间里，人类生活在自然世界中，依靠大自然获取食物和住所。
The amount of time we've spent in urban dwellings is a small sliver of the total time humans have spent on Earth. When you look at it this way, our shift from forest life to freeways and overflowing cities has been very recent and very dramatic. So how is this shift affecting our health, our mood, and our sense of calm?
我们居住在城市里的时间，只是人类在地球上生存总时长的一小部分。从这个角度来看，我们从森林生活向高速公路和拥挤城市的转变是非常近期且剧烈的。那么，这种转变如何影响我们的健康、情绪和内心的平静感呢？
This week on Hidden Brain, think deeply. We continue our annual summer series, YouTube.O. Authenticity is contagious. I have been dragged into this all the way kicking and screaming. Ideas and advice about how you can respond to life's chaos. Just do it, just check to my inbox. Just chaos. You do it just check to my inbox. Just check, just check, just check to my phone real quick. With wisdom. Ming-Kuo has been studying the effects of nature on humans for more than 30 years. She works at the University of Illinois or Banna-Champaign. Early in her career, Ming studied research looking at the well-being of animals in zoos. Researchers found that even when animals were provided all the basics of food,
本周的《Hidden Brain》，让我们深入思考。我们将继续年度夏季系列节目“YouTube.O”。真实具有感染力。我一直被拖进这一切，又踢又叫。关于如何应对生活混乱的观点和建议。去做吧，去看看我的收件箱。只是混乱。你去做吧，去看看我的收件箱。去看看，去看看，去看看我的手机。带着智慧。明·郭（Ming-Kuo）研究自然对人类的影响已经超过30年了。她在伊利诺伊大学厄巴纳-香槟分校工作。在职业生涯早期，明研究了动物园里动物的福祉。研究人员发现，即使为动物提供了食物、
safety, and shelter, they often failed to thrive. It turns out that zoo animals, first of all, are extremely expensive. They die at fairly alarming clips. And so, biologists have studied animals in the wild, and one of the ideas that they have is that there's this thing called habitat selection theory, which is that we are, we're wired for whatever habitat we evolved in. And so there seems to be this general kind of rule that animals who are in their quote unquote natural habitats will do much better. They thrive both in terms of physically will do much better they thrive both in terms of physically and psychologically and in terms of their social behaviors. So if zoo animals thrive in their natural habitat, some researchers have asked,
安全和住所等基本需求，它们往往也无法茁壮成长。事实证明，动物园里的动物首先是非常昂贵的。它们的死亡率相当惊人。因此，生物学家研究了野生动物，他们提出的观点之一是存在所谓的“栖息地选择理论”，即我们天生适应我们进化而来的栖息地。因此，似乎存在一条普遍规则：处于所谓“自然栖息地”中的动物表现会好得多。它们在生理、心理以及社会行为方面都能茁壮成长。所以，如果动物园里的动物在自然栖息地中能茁壮成长，一些研究人员不禁会问，
could this also be true for humans? Given that humans first evolved in the forest of Africa, could it be that depriving humans of this natural environment has effect similar to housing a zebra in a cage? We'll get to Ming's answer to that question in a moment, but first it's important to understand how she came to be studying this in the first place. She wasn't particularly interested in the benefits of greenery and nature. She was interested in the negative effects of noise and crowding. The way I got into the research on the effects of the natural environments on people was
这对人类是否也适用？鉴于人类最初是在非洲的森林中进化的，剥夺人类这种自然环境是否会产生类似于把斑马关在笼子里的影响？我们稍后会谈到明对这个问题的回答，但首先，了解她最初是如何开始这项研究的很重要。她并不是特别对绿地和自然的好处感兴趣。她感兴趣的是噪音和拥挤的负面影响。我开始研究自然环境对人的影响是因为
I was interested in the dark side of the environment. I was interested in how violent or dangerous or bad urban environments had detrimental effects on people. And I only got into this by accident. And then I only came up with this view of the effects of nature through the data. So I have been kind of dragged. I have been dragged into this all the way, kicking and screaming. I did not have that view of people
我对环境的阴暗面很感兴趣。我对暴力、危险或糟糕的城市环境如何对人产生有害影响很感兴趣。我只是偶然进入这个领域的。后来，我只是通过数据才形成了关于自然影响的这种观点。所以我算是被拖进来的。我一直被拖进这一切，又踢又叫。我并没有那种需要去验证的
that I set out to test. I came upon that view because I was trying to make sense of what the findings have been. I'm glad you said that because you know this idea that people need greenery or that greenery is essential to human satisfaction, well-being, thriving. When I first heard that, I sort of said that sounds like a really feel-good idea that I could hear in a new age magazine. And I find it appealing that in some ways you were a skeptic yourself that for a long time, you found this idea to be sort of squishy.
关于人的观点。我得出那个观点是因为我试图理解研究结果。我很高兴你这么说，因为你知道，这种认为人们需要绿地，或者绿地对人类的满足感、幸福感和成长至关重要的观点，当我第一次听到时，我心想，这听起来像是在新时代杂志上能听到的那种让人感觉良好的想法。我发现，在某种程度上，你本人曾经也是个怀疑论者，很长一段时间里，你觉得这个想法有点虚无缥缈，这很有意思。
Yeah. I think like a lot of people, I thought of the environment as trees, grass, gardens, flowers. I thought of that as kind of a nice amenity, they're not functional, right? They're not what we need. And so it's only when you look at the patterns of what people are like with more and less access to nature that you start to see this pattern where, gosh, you know, we
是的。我想和很多人一样，我把环境看作是树木、草地、花园、花朵。我把这些看作是一种不错的点缀，它们不是功能性的，对吧？它们不是我们所必需的。所以，只有当你观察那些接触自然程度不同的人群表现出的模式时，你才会开始看到这种规律，天哪，你知道，我们
see the same thing in humans that we see in zoo and lab animals, which is the wonderful quote from E.O. Wilson is that organisms, when housed in unfit habitats, undergo social, psychological, and physical breakdown. And we are seeing precisely that in people. So when you have people who have a certain amount of access to nature, and then you give them a bit more, you see better social functioning, you see better psychological functioning and better physical health. In some ways this argument is saying that humans today or many humans today are living in the kind of conditions that we used to keep zoo
在人类身上看到了我们在动物园和实验室动物身上看到的东西，正如E.O.威尔逊那句精彩的名言所说，生物如果被安置在不适宜的栖息地中，就会经历社会、心理和生理上的崩溃。我们在人类身上看到的正是这一点。所以，当人们拥有一定程度的自然接触，然后你给他们更多一点时，你会看到更好的社会功能、更好的心理功能和更好的身体健康。在某种程度上，这个论点是在说，今天的人类，或者说今天许多人类，正生活在50年前我们用来安置动物园
animals in 50 years ago. I mean obviously we are doing better by a lot of humans than most zoo animals did in the old days but I think we are to some extent housing homo sapiens with that same functional view, that okay, well, as long as they have shelter, water, food, safety, you know, that's pretty good. That should do it, right? And then anything else beyond that is sort of a plus and it's nice. It's yummy, but it's not important. It's nice, it's yummy, but it's not important.
动物的那种条件下。我的意思是，显然我们对待许多人类的方式比过去对待大多数动物园动物要好，但我认为我们在某种程度上正以同样的功利视角安置智人，即“好吧，只要他们有住所、水、食物、安全，这就很不错了。这就足够了，对吧？”除此之外的任何东西都只是加分项，是锦上添花。它很好，很令人愉悦，但并不重要。它很好，很令人愉悦，但并不重要。
I want to take you methodically through some of the empirical evidence that persuaded you that this was more than just a feel good theory. And I'm wondering if we could start with the studies that you and others have conducted in Chicago. Walk me through this research, starting with the study that you conducted
我想带你系统地了解一些说服你的实证证据，证明这不仅仅是一个让人感觉良好的理论。我想知道我们是否可以从你和其他人在芝加哥进行的研究开始。带我了解一下这项研究，从你在
at the Robert Taylor Homes. Sure. So Robert Taylor Homes is a, or was, a series of 16, 10 story buildings, sort of along a particular corridor in Chicago. And they were originally designed with greenery all around them. But over time, as you can imagine, if you have a ton of kids running around in a courtyard space, you don't have much money for maintenance. If it rains, they get mud everywhere and the grass gets trampled and it very quickly tends to die. And so there are very few cases in which the building managers didn't end up just paving over what used to be grassy areas.
罗伯特·泰勒住宅区（Robert Taylor Homes）进行的研究开始。当然。罗伯特·泰勒住宅区是一系列位于芝加哥某条走廊沿线的16栋10层建筑。它们最初设计时周围都有绿地。但随着时间的推移，你可以想象，如果有一大群孩子在庭院里跑来跑去，而你又没有多少钱进行维护。如果下雨，到处都是泥，草地被踩踏，很快就会枯死。因此，在很多情况下，物业经理最终只能把曾经的草地铺平。
And so if you pavor those areas, take the trees out, then you just have asphalt. So we have this beautiful kind of experiment where people are randomly assigned to different buildings that are identical and some of those buildings have a bit of trees and grass around them and some of them don't. And we just went about studying what the outcomes were in those different buildings. And what did you find? Well, we looked at a bunch of things but I think the sort of short answer is we found we found social breakdown in buildings without trees and grass around them.
所以如果你把那些区域铺平，移走树木，剩下的就只有沥青了。所以我们有一个非常好的实验，人们被随机分配到相同的建筑中，其中一些建筑周围有一些树木和草地，而另一些则没有。我们只是去研究这些不同建筑里的结果。你发现了什么？嗯，我们观察了很多事情，但我认为简短的回答是，我们在周围没有树木和草地的建筑里发现了社会崩溃。
That is to say, when we asked people, did they know their neighbors, did they speak to their neighbors, do they know them on first name basis, could they rely on their neighbors for, you know, for a favor to take care of their kids if they had an emergency. Then the people in the buildings with a bit of greenery were much more likely to say yes. We also found that the folks who are in the less green buildings are reporting more aggressive behaviors. And of course, we had reasons to think this might be the case according to theories.
也就是说，当我们问人们是否认识邻居、是否与邻居交谈、是否知道邻居的名字、在紧急情况下是否能指望邻居帮忙照顾孩子时，住在有绿地建筑里的人更有可能回答“是”。我们还发现，住在绿化较少建筑里的人报告了更多的攻击性行为。当然，根据理论，我们有理由认为情况可能如此。
So there's this attention restoration theory, which says that when people don't have access to nature they're going to be more mentally fatigued. So when you're mentally fatigued you're also less good at handling difficult social situations. And so we thought, okay, if nature is helpful for rejuvenating people from mental fatigue then folks in buildings who don't have any access to nature are going to be that much more fatigued and that much more irritable and that much more difficulty handling conflict in a productive way. And what's, of course, when we got these findings, we're kind of like, whoa, you know, I mean,
所以有“注意力恢复理论”，它认为当人们无法接触自然时，他们会更容易感到精神疲劳。当你精神疲劳时，处理困难社交情况的能力也会变差。所以我们想，好吧，如果自然有助于让人从精神疲劳中恢复，那么住在没有任何自然接触的建筑里的人会更加疲劳、更加易怒，在以建设性的方式处理冲突时也会遇到更多困难。当然，当我们得到这些发现时，我们当时想，哇，你知道，我的意思是，
I know the theory predicts this, but I didn't think we'd actually get it. And so I did a follow up when involving Chicago Police Department crime statistics. They were very good about giving us two years worth of crime statistics. From another development, we wanted to see if this general effect showed up in other Chicago public housing developments. So we looked at a low rise one instead of a high rise, and we see the same pattern in police records of crime. So it can't just be that people living in close proximity to trees maybe have rosier memories of their interactions with others. In fact, hypothetically, you're seeing maybe the same amount of disagreement and conflict, but people are just remembering it differently. You're saying
我知道理论预测了这一点，但我没想到我们真的能得到它。所以我做了一个后续研究，涉及芝加哥警察局的犯罪统计数据。他们非常配合，给了我们两年的犯罪统计数据。从另一个开发项目来看，我们想看看这种普遍影响是否出现在芝加哥的其他公共住房项目中。所以我们观察了一个低层建筑而不是高层建筑，我们在犯罪记录中看到了同样的模式。所以这不可能仅仅是因为住在树木附近的人可能对与他人的互动有更美好的回忆。事实上，假设你看到的冲突和分歧数量可能是一样的，但人们只是记忆的方式不同。你是说
the police records in some ways provide an objective measure that there actually is less conflict in these buildings. Right, exactly. So, I'm wondering about other confounding things in the study. I mean, is it possible that apartment buildings with more green space had different numbers of people living in them? You know, the buildings themselves were identical, but is it possible there were fewer people for some reason living in the greener buildings? And what you're measuring is really related to crowding and not related to green space.
警察记录在某种程度上提供了一个客观的衡量标准，证明这些建筑里的冲突确实较少。没错，正是这样。所以，我想知道研究中是否存在其他混杂因素。我的意思是，绿地较多的公寓楼里居住的人数是否可能不同？你知道，建筑本身是一样的，但有没有可能因为某种原因，绿化较好的建筑里住的人更少？而你测量的实际上与拥挤有关，而不是与绿地有关。
Good question. But as you remember, those were the variables I cared about. So I wanted about, is there more noise, or was there more crowding? What else is going on in these buildings? And so, because I was interested, I made sure to measure all of those things. And it turns out that those did not explain their relationship.
好问题。但正如你所记得的，那些是我关心的变量。所以我关心的是，噪音是否更多，或者拥挤是否更多？这些建筑里还发生了什么？因为我感兴趣，所以我确保测量了所有这些因素。事实证明，这些并不能解释它们之间的关系。
So let's just take crowding as an example. If there was crowding, then it didn't fit the pattern that the violence fit, or it didn't fit the pattern of the green space, or both. I understand there's been research done out of Columbia University in the University of Pennsylvania that has explored what happens when you green parts of a city add more trees and grass to parts of a city that this has measurable effects not just from the quality of life but even on the crime rate. Right, and the numbers are really pretty startling. So these researchers worked with the city to coordinate their vacant lot program. And basically what they did was they designated a bunch of vacant lots as eligible for cleaning
所以让我们以拥挤为例。如果存在拥挤，那么它不符合暴力发生的模式，或者它不符合绿地的模式，或者两者都不符合。据我了解，哥伦比亚大学和宾夕法尼亚大学进行的研究探讨了当你在城市部分地区增加绿化、在城市部分地区增加更多树木和草地时会发生什么，这不仅对生活质量有可衡量的影响，甚至对犯罪率也有影响。没错，这些数字确实相当惊人。所以这些研究人员与市政府合作协调了他们的空地项目。基本上他们所做的是指定了一堆空地作为有资格进行清理
and greening. Quote unquote. So that involves taking out all the trash, bits of glass, cigarette butts, cleaning it up, putting in some turf grass, you know, nice panel of lawn, and then some trees. So fairly inexpensive intervention, and they randomly assigned which lots would get this intervention and which ones would not, and then they tracked what happened in those lots afterwards.
和绿化的对象。所谓“绿化”，就是清理掉所有的垃圾、玻璃碎片、烟头，清理干净，铺上一些草皮，你知道，漂亮的草坪，然后种上一些树。所以这是一个相当廉价的干预措施，他们随机分配了哪些地块会得到这种干预，哪些不会，然后他们追踪了之后在这些地块上发生的事情。
And it turns out that in the lots that receive this intervention, gun assaults go down by police records, 9.1%, which is really, like, boy, if we have anything that cost any amount of money that can reduce gun assaults by 9% in a city, any mayor in the US is going to trump at that. And we see similar patterns for burglaries and other complaints. So, it's a very exciting finding.
结果发现，在接受这种干预的地块中，根据警方记录，枪支袭击事件减少了9.1%，这真的让人觉得，天哪，如果我们有任何花费并不多就能让城市枪支袭击减少9%的方法，美国任何一位市长都会为此欢呼。我们在入室盗窃和其他投诉中也看到了类似的模式。所以，这是一个非常令人兴奋的发现。
If I recall correctly, wasn't there a time maying when actually police had the opposite intuition? They actually thought that having trees and bushes could actually increase crime because it gave bad guys places to hide and in some ways it made surveillance easier if you actually eliminated all of that and that's just that open lots or just things paved over. Right, there was that belief and in fact there is something to that intuition but it's fairly limited. So if you have a lot of basically brush and undercover,
如果我没记错的话，明，是不是曾经有一段时间警察有相反的直觉？他们实际上认为拥有树木和灌木可能会增加犯罪，因为它给坏人提供了藏身之处，而且在某种程度上，如果你消除了所有这些，只留下开阔的地块或铺平的地面，监控会更容易。没错，确实有那种信念，事实上这种直觉也有一定道理，但它是相当有限的。所以如果你有很多灌木丛和遮蔽物，
that can in certain circumstances, particularly in park settings, depending on lines of visibility, then yes, a large bush can provide a place to hide drugs or a gun or whatever. And at the same time, what we see is that if you have limbed up trees, trees that do not block visibility at eye level, the consistent finding is more trees less crime. What was your reaction being as a researcher in some ways who wasn't necessarily looking for this finding?
在某些情况下，特别是在公园环境中，取决于视线，那么是的，大灌木丛确实可以提供藏毒品或枪支或其他东西的地方。与此同时，我们看到的是，如果你有修剪过的树木，即那些不会阻挡视线高度的树木，一致的发现是树木越多，犯罪越少。作为一名研究人员，在某种程度上并没有刻意寻找这个发现，你的反应是什么？
And in some ways, as I'm detecting, was sort of somewhat skeptical about sort of the overall relationship between nature and these positive things. What was your reaction when you got these results? I mean, to be a scientist, to be a good scientist is to be a skeptic, you know. So even when you have a theory that's your pet theory and this was by no means my pet theory. Your job is to try to figure out is there some way this we could have found this without my pet theory being true. And so I'll tell you a related story. My old advisor, Rachel Kaplan, who's one of the giants in this field, she did her work for decades
而且在某种程度上，正如我所察觉到的，你对自然与这些积极事物之间的整体关系持某种怀疑态度。当你得到这些结果时，你的反应是什么？我的意思是，成为一名科学家，成为一名优秀的科学家就是要成为一名怀疑论者，你知道。所以即使你有一个理论是你的“宠儿理论”，而这绝不是我的宠儿理论。你的工作是试图找出，有没有可能我们在我的宠儿理论不成立的情况下也发现了这一点。所以我给你讲一个相关的故事。我的老导师雷切尔·卡普兰（Rachel Kaplan），她是这个领域的泰斗之一，她工作了几十年
in a building at the University of Michigan that faces onto a brick interior courtyard, just bricks and gravel at the bottom. So she spends her career there 30, 40 years. I don't know how many years, right? And then over time, she does stpendous work and the university finally decides to give her a named chair, a professorship, sort of a very fancy position. And at the same time, they're renovating the building and they move Rachel into a third
在密歇根大学的一栋建筑里，那栋楼对着一个砖砌的内部庭院，底部只有砖块和砾石。所以她在那里工作了30、40年。我不知道多少年，对吧？然后随着时间的推移，她做出了惊人的工作，大学最终决定给她一个冠名教授职位，这是一种非常高级的职位。与此同时，他们正在翻新大楼，把雷切尔搬到了三楼
floor corner office in the trees. It's right in the canopy. And her office is all windows. And she says to me, you know, I have been studying this for how many decades, and now I know it's really true. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. For years, Minkuo has studied how nature affects us and how the lack of access to nature can lead to crime and social breakdown. It turns out this is only part of the story. There's also a relationship between nature and our physical and mental health.
拐角处的办公室，就在树丛中。她的办公室全是窗户。她对我说，你知道，我研究这个研究了几十年，现在我知道这是真的。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。多年来，明·郭研究了自然如何影响我们，以及缺乏自然接触如何导致犯罪和社会崩溃。事实证明，这只是故事的一部分。自然与我们的身心健康之间也存在联系。
Ming says there seems to be a connection between greenery and health markers for obesity, hypertension, and diabetes. So I did a review of the scientific literature and I found every bit of evidence I could that tied greenery to long-term health outcomes. So for instance, one of the things we find is that when you look out at a green landscape even from indoors, your heart rate will go down and you'll change from sympathetic
明说，绿地与肥胖、高血压和糖尿病的健康指标之间似乎存在联系。所以我对科学文献进行了回顾，我找到了我能找到的每一条将绿地与长期健康结果联系起来的证据。例如，我们发现的一件事是，当你从室内向外看绿色的景观时，你的心率会下降，你会从交感神经
nervous activity over to parasympathetic nervous activity, which is basically going from what we call fight or flight into tend and befriend mode. So it has these very systematic physiological impacts on us, which we also know have long-term health outcomes associated with them. And I found dozens of health outcomes where long-term health outcomes had been tied to contact with nature, and all of those studies, I threw out anything that didn't take into account
活动转变为副交感神经活动，这基本上是从我们所谓的“战斗或逃跑”模式转变为“照料与结盟”模式。所以它对我们有非常系统的生理影响，我们也知道这些影响与长期的健康结果相关。我发现了数十种健康结果，这些长期健康结果与接触自然有关，在所有这些研究中，我剔除了任何没有考虑
socioeconomic status. It is no surprise that we would find rich people tend to have greener neighborhoods and better health outcomes. I was interested in let's take two people, same income, same life circumstances, except for the greenery. And what do we see in terms of health outcomes there? Let's talk a little bit about the socio-economic surface. As you and others have pointed out, there is an enormous disparity in many countries, not just between the rich and the poor, but in neighborhoods that are green and neighborhoods that are not green. And in many ways, this lines up with disparities between the rich and the poor.
社会经济地位的研究。富人往往有更绿色的社区和更好的健康结果，这并不奇怪。我感兴趣的是，让我们找两个人，收入相同，生活环境相同，除了绿地不同。我们在那里的健康结果方面看到了什么？让我们谈谈社会经济层面。正如你和其他人指出的那样，许多国家存在巨大的差异，不仅是在富人和穷人之间，而且在有绿化的社区和没有绿化的社区之间。在许多方面，这与富人和穷人之间的差异是一致的。
Rich neighborhoods tend to be greener, poor neighborhoods tend to be less green. How much of what you are seeing is it possible that some of this is actually just related to differences in wealth that then produce all kinds of other health consequences, or do you think this is actually connected just to the greenery itself? Well, that's exactly the concern, right? We already knew that wealthier people have better health outcomes and more greenery, so then how do you compare? And basically, what you do is you look for people who have the exact same person A in the screen neighborhood and person B in the snacking neighborhood, you want to make sure persons A and B have the same income. So all of these comparisons in
富裕社区往往更绿，贫困社区往往绿化较少。你所看到的有多少可能是与财富差异有关，而财富差异又产生了各种其他健康后果，还是你认为这实际上与绿地本身有关？嗯，这正是令人担忧的地方，对吧？我们已经知道富人有更好的健康结果和更多的绿地，那么你如何进行比较呢？基本上，你所做的是寻找那些完全相同的人，屏幕上的A和零食区的B，你要确保A和B有相同的收入。所以所有这些比较
this review I did were taking that into account. One of my favorite studies in this area comes from an analysis of pharmacies in London and the medications they dispense. And there's a connection between this and the amount of greenery in different neighborhoods in London. What are the study fine? So pharmacies in London are neighborhood-based. So pretty much people go to the pharmacy that's in their neighborhood.
我做的这项回顾都考虑到了这一点。在这个领域，我最喜欢的研究之一来自对伦敦药房及其分发的药物的分析。这与伦敦不同社区的绿地数量之间存在联系。这项研究发现了什么？所以伦敦的药房是基于社区的。所以基本上人们去他们社区里的药房。
And they know how green it is around each pharmacy. And they also know how many people live there, how many people the pharmacy serves. And they know prescriptions for mood related, you know, anxiety disorder medications and depression medications. And they just compared for pharmacies that compare the same number of people with the same rough income. How many more mood medications are they prescribing? And it's substantially larger.
他们知道每家药房周围有多绿。他们也知道有多少人住在那里，药房服务多少人。他们知道与情绪相关的处方，你知道，焦虑症药物和抑郁症药物。他们只是比较了服务相同人数、收入大致相同的药房。他们开了多少情绪类药物？结果是显著增加。
The less greenery is around the neighborhood. There also appears to be a relationship between greenery and the strength of our immune systems. After people spend several days in nature, researchers find measurable increases in what are known as natural killer cells. After a three-day weekend in a forest preserve, that boosts natural killer cells on average by 50%. And a three-day weekend in a nice urban area turns out doesn't do anything for your natural killer cells. And then if I come, come knock on your door 30 days later after your three-day weekend, and I say, can I have another sample of your blood please?
社区周围的绿地越少。绿地与我们免疫系统的强度之间似乎也存在关系。在人们在自然中度过几天后，研究人员发现所谓的“自然杀伤细胞”有可衡量的增加。在森林保护区度过一个三天的小长假后，自然杀伤细胞平均增加了50%。而在一个不错的城市地区度过三天小长假，结果对你的自然杀伤细胞没有任何作用。然后如果我来，在你三天小长假30天后敲你的门，我说，我能再要一份你的血液样本吗？
And you give it to me. It will show that you are still roughly 24, 25 percent above your baseline number of natural killer cells. So it's a big effect and it lasts for a really long time. What do you think is going on here, Ming? I mean, is it just the things we see when we're out in nature, is the things we smell, is it just the things we see when we're out in nature, is it things we smell, is it just the experience of being out in nature, is it the perception, is that what's driving these effects, do you think? Well, the answer is yes.
你给了我。它会显示你的自然杀伤细胞水平仍然比基线水平高出大约24%到25%。所以这是一个很大的影响，而且持续时间非常长。你认为这里发生了什么，明？我的意思是，这只是我们在自然中看到的东西，是我们闻到的东西，是身处自然中的体验，是感知，你认为是什么在驱动这些影响？嗯，答案是肯定的。
So it turns out that if we take people and put them in a lab, and we just show them pictures of nature, and we watch what happens to their blood pressure and their nervous system activity. We can see them become more calm. So just the visual is enough. Similarly, if I take you into a lab and I spritz what we call fight insides, which are these essential aromatic compounds that you associate with woods. So if I spritz you with fight insides,
所以事实证明，如果我们把人带进实验室，只给他们看自然的图片，观察他们的血压和神经系统活动会发生什么。我们可以看到他们变得更加平静。所以仅仅是视觉就足够了。同样，如果我把你带进实验室，喷洒我们所谓的“植物杀菌素”，这是你与森林联系在一起的必需芳香化合物。所以如果我给你喷洒植物杀菌素，
you don't have to be in a pine forest. I can see changes in your natural killer cells and in your bloodstream. So of course, if you're a mad scientist, you would say, well, really all you have to do is make sure that people's green savers are set to pictures of forests. And you sort of pipe in some, you know,
你不需要身处松树林中。我可以看到你的自然杀伤细胞和血液中的变化。所以当然，如果你是一个疯狂的科学家，你会说，好吧，实际上你所要做的就是确保人们的绿色保护区设置为森林图片。然后你通过公共广播系统播放一些，你知道，
sounds of the forest over the public address system, and you spritz the air with some eucalyptus, and you're done. Well, you will have a measurable positive effect. If I give you vitamin D, and I give you vitamin A, then that takes care of your D and A deficiency, but it doesn't take care of your B and C deficiencies. So nature seems to be like a multivitamin. You can get different benefits from different kinds of exposure, you know, right, the spritzing versus the visual versus the smell or whatever. But to get all of them, you have kind of have to be there.
森林的声音，并在空气中喷洒一些桉树精油，你就完成了。好吧，你会有一个可衡量的积极影响。如果我给你维生素D，再给你维生素A，那么这解决了你的D和A缺乏症，但它不能解决你的B和C缺乏症。所以自然似乎就像一种多种维生素。你可以从不同类型的接触中获得不同的好处，你知道，对吧，喷洒与视觉与气味等等。但要获得所有这些，你必须身处其中。
So I'm wondering how do you take this multivitamin everyday, Ming? You've started out as a skeptic and you've gradually come to be persuaded by the evidence. Have you found ways to actually apply these insights to your own life? I live about a 10 minute walk from the university from the campus and I do something which probably looks completely ridiculous to the average person driving by me. I walk two and from school with my eyes in the canopy. I fly through the trees on the way to school and I fly through the trees on the way back from campus. And I have, so my head is up, I probably at danger of tripping, I look ridiculous, but
所以我很好奇你每天是如何服用这种多种维生素的，明？你最初是一个怀疑论者，后来逐渐被证据说服。你有没有找到将这些见解应用到自己生活中的方法？我住的地方离大学校园大约10分钟步行路程，我做了一件在开车经过的普通人看来可能完全荒谬的事情。我走路去学校和从学校回来时，眼睛都盯着树冠。我在去学校的路上穿过树林，在回校园的路上也穿过树林。所以我的头是抬着的，我可能面临绊倒的危险，我看起来很荒谬，但是
it makes a real difference for me. And once I started adopting that, I have become hooked. Ming-Ko's studies the effects that nature has on human beings. come hooked. Ming Co. studies the effects that nature has on human beings. She's a researcher at the University of Illinois at Urbana-Champaign. Ming, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. This week's show was produced by Thomas Liu and edited by Tara Boyle.
它对我来说确实产生了真正的不同。一旦我开始采用这种方式，我就上瘾了。明·郭研究自然对人类的影响。上瘾了。明·郭研究自然对人类的影响。她是伊利诺伊大学厄巴纳-香槟分校的研究员。明，非常感谢你今天参加《Hidden Brain》。非常感谢。本周的节目由托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。
Artimian Clude Zrena Cohen, Jenny Schmidt, Parth Shah and Laura Correll. Our unsung hero is Emily Blackman, who oversees events at the Chesapeake Bay Foundation. We had a staff retreat at the Foundation's headquarters some time ago, and Emily made sure that everything ran smoothly. Her work gave us a chance to take a breath and connect with nature and with each other. It was a wonderful day and we're truly grateful. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please be sure to share it with someone you know. We're always looking for new listeners
Artimian Clude Zrena Cohen, Jenny Schmidt, Parth Shah 和 Laura Correll。我们的无名英雄是艾米丽·布莱克曼（Emily Blackman），她负责切萨皮克湾基金会（Chesapeake Bay Foundation）的活动。前段时间我们在基金会总部举行了员工静修会，艾米丽确保了一切顺利进行。她的工作让我们有机会喘口气，与自然和彼此建立联系。那是非常美好的一天，我们真心感激。想了解更多《Hidden Brain》，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必分享给你认识的人。我们一直在寻找新的听众
to Hidden Brain. We're always looking for new listeners to hit and brain. Next week, authenticity is contagious. We continue our YouTube.O series with an episode about rebelling against norms. Once we see people making themselves vulnerable rather than judging them negatively, we actually respect them and we ask ourselves questions about why is it that we're covering up. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加入《Hidden Brain》。我们一直在寻找新的听众加入《Hidden Brain》。下周，真实具有感染力。我们将继续我们的“YouTube.O”系列，这一集是关于反抗规范的。一旦我们看到人们展现脆弱而不是消极地评判他们，我们实际上会尊重他们，并问自己为什么我们要掩饰。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。